what you want to hear a rap about okay
I'm gonna ask you to say that again
slowly Tegucigalpa so obviously I know
what that means but for the benefit of
everyone else in the room what's to
watch Tegucigalpa me my friend the
capital of Honduras Tegucigalpa make
noise if you knew that one down front
just teacher's pet I did Tegucigalpa the
capital Honduras thank you very much
people over here maybe that's make it
easier than Tegucigalpa the capital of
Honduras what do you study
that's I love that you were just going
did you did you and then saw went
teacher II - yeah victory - victory -
okay teacher II to Tegucigalpa so far
it's just noises guys didgeridoo
Tegucigalpa this half of the middle what
you want to write bow oh there were two
at the same time I heard Spanish
galleons what did you say
gymnastics okay did you say that's a
good one you found in gymnastics jeju-do
do gymnastics yeah what type of
gymnastics you can't say that's a good
one yes I do gymnastics no I don't do
gymnastics
you're worse than didgeridoo lady over
there what type of gymnastics bounce
beam thank you very much gymnastics
specifically bounce beam Tegucigalpa
didgeridoo and Spanish galleons let's
take one final one this this kind of air
who haven't come to what you want to rap
about Canada yeah what specific aspect
of Canada do you want us to kind of
focus on what was that oh okay by aspect
of Canada I was mean like their
politeness or predilection for maple
syrup you were like no Ontario so we
have to goose a girl for an Ontario two
places I've never been and know nothing
about that'll be fine so
Tegucigalpa didgeridoo Spanish galleons
gymnastic specifically the bounce beam
and Canada brackets Ontario this then
lovely people see I go at the end of the
show cuz usually this like a big amazing
thing but tonight I think it's gonna be
absolute [ __ ]
I think it's gonna be awful should we
roll that beat let's do it a freestyle
rap made up entirely on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions and crank
a low B as well a little bit pumps this
of freaky beat as well I'm doing ya
feelin so keen on the floor on the map
Nara truth about speed yet sprue the
bars parallel I'll be holding on as well
bouncer jumpin up everybody in the crowd
de yell at me to you cuz I call the
balance dexterity I'm amazing
yeah they admire it they are like Chris
the baton is so hard I look damn good in
the love a leotard you can see Papa
shame legs no hair there I'm on the
bounce bar and I do take care beds got a
balance and I got balance evils don't
have cause they've got talents where the
evils go America where the Eagles never
go Canada is just moose up there we all
know I know to Quebec and then Ontario
what is their absolute
barren wasteland sleep the size of
Canada massive like my hand please don't
try and clap it's really not a tree it's
hard for anybody else to stick to this
beat I can do it though I blow till my
face is blue I'm a fan so I can play the
didgeridoo that's not this such a nice
thing statement to say the aboriginal
people may lady stay away
they are like now only played by the
blokes I was in Australia and they spoke
to me like a day mate do you wanna play
a little tune take this tree then blow
away water my life it's wood with
termites amazing I've got an accent like
Dick Van Dyke did it Mary Poppins a
rapper bar hunter Earth has no way of
stopping me stay in I went there you
know I felt an urge to go to Tegucigalpa
like Chris you can rap freely in
Honduras I won't carry on it would boy
yes you will be like Brisco we've heard
all the stories immigration from Central
America stand from Tegucigalpa come in
to hear lemon and ask him what the
capital means have never understood
before the last thing I've seen is on
the English Channel come in The Horizon
the Armada trying to surprise Elizabeth
the first
she was our queen god Francis Drake he
was mighty coming after the Spanish
ships to split your mind I don't you
don't really take the time to study
British history
early military battalions they are the
Spanish ships they see they really
picked galleons I see a lotta galleons
that the currency and Harry Potter maybe
that makes more sense
coming from Madrid speed six ride since
I was a little kid there we go
I did it was meant to be a deep
gymnastics but mentally yeah
haha yeah boy